for Sims I believe is with us after
giving me the silent treatment with that
hard-hitting question how long do you
think it takes for Tom Brady to surpass
your records with the template
Buccaneers yeah not long I mean between
him and Bruce Arians offense and that
the weapons he's got down there in Tampa
I don't think it'll probably be week
four somewhere in there something like
that well you had 12 career touchdown
passes with the Buccaneer so yes yeah it
might take you two months to get there
maybe maybe I think you know they're
gonna throw the football but yeah I mean
I would definitely be worried about week
four you know it goes you know three
touchdowns a game early on they come out
on fire but yet my records definitely
gonna go down to Brady that's for sure
all right the big concern you have with
this marriage with Brady and the
Buccaneers is what I really only have
one concern and to me you know it's a
little bit this is why I didn't know if
it would work or happen in general love
the offense Brady can still push the
ball down the field you've know this Dan
the one thing I have a concern with with
Brady more than anything about his play
right now is just want to his ability to
stand in the pocket and take punishment
and you know let's say there's a 20-yard
in cut right the 20 yard in cutter of
five yard underneath grass I thought he
was very quick to get to the 5 yard
underneath route last year and didn't
want to stand in there and make some of
the harder throws and take the hit that
would be my only thing when I watch on
film that is a concern for me with Tom
Brady and you know it's a little extra
in this marriage because Bruce Arians is
he's one of the hey no risk it no
biscuit you got to hold the ball all day
here because I want to throw the ball 20
30 40 50 yards downfield and I think you
know Brady's gonna have to get used to
that style of play but I think it's
certainly possible and you know Ariens
is such a great way about it I think
he'll be able to push Brady in those
ways to to get better at it do you think
it's just a coincidence that he went to
a coach who is the polar opposite of the
coach he's been with the last 20 years
you know you know I said that right away
last night when it hat or yesterday we
heard the dudes I was like well
everything
he's not getting in New England he'll
get in Tampa uh I I don't know I I think
it's a little bit of a coincidence I
think it's refreshing to him so no yeah
I guess I'm saying no it's not a
coincidence I think it's refreshing to
him I do I'm sure he's talked to Bruce
area there's like wow man this head
coach is like talking to me like a
normal human being like we're equals
he's telling me jokes you know those are
things bill just doesn't cross the line
there very often with his players he's
the general and he he continues to wear
that general hat as long as you're on
that team with him so no I would think
that was part of it you know and and
just the the the support system around
them with the receivers and the tight
ends we're probably all a big part
they're gonna roll the red carpet out
there Dan I know people think like the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and oh they can't
sell out stadiums and all that you know
that is a awesome fan base I will stick
up for them to the day I die they love
their football now not everybody might
have enough money to go around and buy
season tickets all the time but they
love the Bucs and he's gonna be treated
like king in that town that's for sure
do you think the Patriots wanted in back
I think they wanted them back only at a
really almost disrespectful price
probably somewhere there you know the
thing I think that they probably could
have offered Brady 20 23 million dollars
if he told them early on like hey I want
to come back let's do this I thought
when they franchise tag Joe SUNY which I
don't think they wanted to do they were
hoping to work out a long-term deal and
they say Devin McCourty
one of the first things I thought was oh
wow that might take away some of their
wiggle room here to throw some extra
change at Brady and not that I know that
but that kind of seems what what
happened it kind of seemed to all go
downhill from that point on and yeah III
think they would have accepted them back
but I think they're certainly looking to
the future and no news at this time had
to come sooner or later and Belichick is
one to make these tough decisions and
move on all right let's look into other
moves here how much of an upgrade is
Phillip Rivers for the Colts well he's
definitely an upgrade from Jacoby perset
you know Jacoby % fell apart at the
second half of the season last year
and something I've been saying on my pod
in the show a lot is just you know I had
been informed there is no way Jacobi
burchett was gonna be the starting
quarterback for the Colts at the end
after about three or four weeks so he
isn't upgrade you know he has a little
history with Frank Reich there's gonna
be familiarity with the offense so he's
gonna hit the ground running and yes I
think it'll give their whole
organization confidence the offense
confident and yes I do think Phillip
Rivers is better than Jacoby perset
Teddy Bridgewater to the Panthers
well that that I mean I mean I was
probably mean with the Shockers a day
the thing they're you know and you
probably know this but you know just
connect the dots I mean Bridgewater has
been in New Orleans you know the Sean
Payton offense Joe Brady the new
offensive coordinator of Carolina he was
in New Orleans you know he's probably
heard a lot of good things about Teddy
Bridgewater too so you know there's a
guy that hey we could start off our new
era the Matt rule era the rebuilding of
that team with a quarterback who
understands the system knows how to play
football and what I always say about
Teddy Bridgewater that's great and
especially a situation like this he
might not win you games but he's not
going to lose you games either yeah and
you know coach some coaches like that
best fit for Cam Newton is where gosh I
mean that's what's really weird about
this one I mean they kind of screwed
over Cam Newton in this conversation
here too you know to unveil this right
now where a lot of you know seats have
been filled here as far as the
quarterback is concerned you know I
would have said Chargers you know like
that that to me would make sense but I
had somebody who I trust about two weeks
ago tell me there's no way that'll
happen now maybe they'll revisit it
maybe they thought they had a chance at
Brady at that time and that's why they
said that I don't know but that would
make sense to me Anthony Lin wants to
run the ball pipe defense he's an ex
running back control the clock Cam
Newton can play that style of football
and he's not necessarily a rhythm passer
where you always need to go all we gotta
get Cam and rhythm now you can run the
ball three plays in a row and then ask
him to throw a 20 yard in cut and he'll
be fine that's kind of what he did in
Carolina
so he's capable of that that's the one
that makes sense to me but I don't know
if that's a real possibility other than
I mean with Chicago I mean that the
Panthers have no leverage here so you
know cams not he's his contract is up
after this year and we know that they're
moving on from them so they're not going
to be able to demand anything you know
top market as far as a trade here the
Bears don't have a lot of picks but
would they flirt with them I don't know
I thought maybe they would be more hot
on Andy Dalton or dick holes for that
position Chris Sims Pro footed again
dude sorry our Sims Pro Football Talk
live co-hosts joining us on the program
explained to me Houston side of the
DeAndre Hopkins trade yeah well I think
the biggest thing is you know they have
an inkling that DeAndre Hopkins is gonna
ask for more money and they are not
comfortable with paying him twenty or
twenty two million dollars a year
DeAndre Hopkins you know the last two
years he's probably looking at things
going wait wait I'm outperforming Julio
Jones and I'm making 10 million dollars
less than him a year so he's got a real
case there to be kind of pissed off
about that and I think Bill O'Brien just
looked at that with the fact that okay I
can't pay him so we're probably gonna
have an issue here sometime in the
future they know they got to pay the
shot Watson David Johnson really fits
what they want to do offensively they
obviously value or not as scared about
David Johnson as we all are yeah there's
some injury history but David Johnson I
mean one healthy he's pretty damn
special he's like a receiver slash
running back he can do everything he
never has to come off the field so he
could be their power back yet also be
you know that's the New England system
be a James White the lowest type out of
the backfield too so I think they saw
the value in that and then of course
they got a second-round pick so you know
I know it at face value it looks like
people are saying Billy O'Brien got
police but not if you don't think you
can pay DeAndre Hopkins and deshaun
Watson both at the same time this is a
movement had to be made and I don't look
at it that way yeah I had heard the same
thing about Hopkins in fact the source I
had put PIAA said Hopkins is is P ia and
I went P ia and he said pain in the ass
and then he was gonna want more money
that he he is overvalued himself with
Houston and that Bill O'Brien has his
short fuse and that's why this he was
going to get traded somewhere in the
offseason from what I was told the
question is where the best team in the
AFC East is oh wow yeah yeah yeah yeah I
like it I like it you know I like it
yeah I'm a huge fan of them
the defense is phenomenal and even here
in free agency I mean hey the big trade
at right watch you know wide receiver to
get stuff on thick they really needed
that he really fits what they do on
offense and then you know just the other
signings they got hey Josh Norman was a
good signing Quintin Jefferson yesterday
Byrne and Butler Mario Addison you know
they're not superstars but they're guys
where you know me I'm Johnny X's and oh
and watch football where I go damn I
mean that is you're gonna have some deep
defensive line that's not going to have
a drop-off between the first and second
team and they're gonna be able to send
waves at you so yeah I'm gonna give
Buffalo the new crown in the AFC East
right now very reluctant to say that
with New England of Belichick but I will
say it for now the logic here with the
Dallas Cowboys and dak Prescott how was
this going to end
I mean I think ultimately it has to end
with that you know paying him what he
wants you know I you know I I don't
understand the last contract offer you
know the guaranteed money and some of
the things why they were less than than
Carson Wentz just buy a few million
dollars like you know just throw it on
there let them don't let them let them
have that who cares you know but I think
ultimately dak Prescott again am I gonna
sit here and tell you he's Patrick
mahomes deshaun Watson Aaron Rodgers
Russell Wilson no he's not in that class
but he's that next group down you know
he's somewhere where you could argue
he's between 6 and 11 maybe 12 on
somebody's quarterback board right Plus
out of the fact he's a phenomenal person
loved by the teammates loved by the
organization in general he really acts
and does and does
all the other little things you want
from a quarterback to which there's
value to that off the field too so I
just think ultimately that that that'll
it'll get done and he'll get his money
yeah but here's my point you said that
every quarterback the next quarterback
up is going to make more than the
previous quarterback that's right the
way it should work I did I've been
banging this table for four I the owners
have cornered themselves into this
conversation I don't know why they keep
doing this either yes you're right if I
was a GM I would go wait no no no you're
not Aaron Rodgers and you're not Russell
Wilson so there's a benchmark right now
and that when you start doing what
they're doing hey then maybe we'll talk
about paying you more but I'm with you I
would not be playing this game same
thing at receiver same thing in all
these positions who said that just
because you're the next guy up you can
paid more than Khalil Mack or Aaron
Donald or whoever it may be that to me
is just insane nobody in defensive
football should make as much money as
Aaron Donald and second is actually
Coolio Mack and until somebody proves
that they're better than that and hey
finally we'll move on and give you more
money but I don't understand some of
these guys who are clearly not there the
player or caliber I'm with you is what
I'm saying all the way your point is
very valid should we bring back the
creamsicle uniforms in Tampa oh man Tom
would look good in those I was always so
pissed I didn't get to wear those damn
you know when I left town when I left
town they broke them out you know the
year they that I finally released me and
I ended up going to the Tennessee Titans
they wore them that year I was so
heartbroken get to wear them but I mean
why not why not find another way to sell
another you know two billion Tom Brady
number 12 jerseys I mean why not Chris
thanks for joining us you the man tell
everybody I said hi dad that's Chris
Sims Pro Football Talk live co-host and
former Tampa Bay Buccaneer legend